notre invité politique ce matin c'est le
vice-président délégué le public un bon
jour guillaume pelletier bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane bern et qui dirige le bureau
parisien du journal ouest france
bonjour stéphane bonjour regarde
guillaume pelletier les députés doivent
se prononcer cet après-midi sur la loi
séparatisme est ce que vous voterez le
texte non pour il ya des bonnes
intentions
l'extrait convient d'entendre de
monsieur kader a été sur cette partie là
juste les certificat de virginité sur la
réaffirmation de principes républicains
mais la question qui fut posée par le
président la république n'est pas celle
ci et la caisse et la réponse
qu'attendent nos compatriotes n'est pas
celle là
les français et nous avec eux nous
voulons nous mais l'ennemi l'ennemi
c'est l'islam politique qui dans nos
quartiers dans nos écoles s'en prend
régulièrement à ce qui fonde l'art de
vivre à la française nos modes de vie
nos traditions et notre culture et
chacun comprend bien qu au delà des
effets d'annoncé et de quelques articles
intéressants
les mots ne sont pas posées et la
sémantique ça compte et qu' il y a trois
grand oublié la question de la laïcité
qui est une question fondamentale
cette loi ne permettra pas par exemple
d'empêcher des petites filles de porter
le voile dans la rue
nous nous pensons que la laci de la
laïcité doit s'imposer partout et pour
tous et que nul ne peut s'exonérer de la
loi commune au nom de sa religion et ce
principe et l as oublié
il n'y a rien sur la question centrale
de l'immigration croire qu'on peut
régler la question de l'islam politique
sans s'attaquer à la question de
l'immigration puisque chacun voit bien
que l'immigration massive conduit à la
concentration des populations qui
conduit au communautarisme qui conduit à
l'islamisme cette loi ne permettra pas
par exemple d'expulser plus facilement
les fichiers s ne s'attaque pas la
question des prisons et enfin plus
subtile peut-être mais tout aussi
important cette loi ne s'attaque pas à
la perte de souveraineté juridique de la
france on se souvient que la cee d âge
par exemple la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme en 2018 a condamné la
france parce que la france voulait
expulser un terroriste algérien on
entend encore récemment du conseil
d'état la dallas défenseurs des droits
des propos d' entité administrative soit
disant indépendante qui de rente
ni au parlement ni au peuple français
des propos qui vont à l'encontre de ce
qui fonde le droit premier d'un peuple à
pouvoir se protéger et se préserver
et pour ces raisons non pas de postures
parce que nous avons tout fait avec les
républicains à travers nos amendements
notre contre-projet nos propositions
pour améliorer ce texte et la quasi
totalité de nos propositions ont été
rejetées
la montagne n'a même pas accouché d'une
souris c'est un tout petit mulot et les
français voient bien que le la guerre
que nous devons mener et gagner et bien
n'est pas au rendez vous et donc c'est
une occasion manquée c'est un rendez
vous raté
du coup vous vous ferez pas vous en avez
compris vous faites répondre vous
obtiendrez contre pour me contre oui et
ça sera la position de votre groupe
ap rio on va se réunir en fin de matinée
en tout cas la semaine dernière lors de
la précédente réunion de groupe à à 90%
des députés des républicaine nous étions
sur cette énigme vous vous attendre si
je vous ai bien compris vous attendiez
quelque chose de beaucoup plus vaste
beaucoup plus large
ce le résultat est étriqué par rapport à
ce que vous ce que vous attendez vous ce
que les français attendent
mais est-ce qu'on peut pas imaginer
qu'un certain nombre de points que vous
venez d'évoquer puisse ne puisse pas
faire l'objet d'autres lois à l'avenir
oui mais rappelez vous suffit pas du
tout en fait là vous avez dans un monde
idéal où nous tout irait presque bien
qu'on prenne le temps est encore
beaucoup de temps très bien mais moi je
n'oublie pas que le président de la
république dès sa campagne
présidentielle a posé des mots très
forts sur le sujet et a promis à
l'occasion d'innombrables discours le
grand rendez vous de son quinquennat
pour lutter contre l'islam politique
lui et sa majorité n'ont même pas osé
nommer l'ennemi quel ambiguïté comme si
les catholiques les juifs les
protestants menaçait la république
moi je crois que le rôle d'un
responsable politique c'est d'être
courageux et de dire la vérité est que
nous n'avons pas le temps qu emmanuel
mais qu'on n'a pas été courageux sur ce
texte
lui et sa majorité ont beaucoup à perdre
et beaucoup promis et très peu tenu et
le rôle notre rôle monde
c'est de dire aux français cette guerre
que nous devons mener et que nous
voulons gagner et que nous gagnerons
si nous voulons faire il faut le dire
avec force et poser des actes clairs
quand j'entends dans une pitoyable
tentative de diversion
monsieur castaner dire que madame le pen
est l'ennemi de la république madame le
pen est une adversaire politique dont on
combat les excès les postures et des
solutions très souvent inopérante
mais qui est l'ennemi de la république
ce sont les terroristes les islamistes
les salafistes les communautaristes ce
sont ceux qui ont tué près de 500
français en france et dans le monde ces
vingt dernières années ce sont ceux qui
s'en prennent à nos soldats au mali 55
morts ce sont ceux qui attrapent s'en
prennent aux professeurs de la
république ce sont ceux qui dans nos
écoles dans nos piscines revendique des
pratiques communautaires contraire à la
tradition française mais qu'est ce que
ne disent pas les ennemis de l'art et de
la majorité se trompent d'ennemi ses sa
a clairement en cire que en tout cas il
ya eu une tentative permanente de double
je sais même plus le en même temps c'est
le double jeu on fait semblant
d'entendre et de comprendre les français
on multiplie un certain nombre de
discours parfois d'ailleurs abouti et
auquel j'adhère et lorsqu'il s'agit de
passer aux actes
eh bien les actes ne sont pas au rendez
vous et je le regrette parce que on est
presque à la fin de son quinquennat et
le grand combat que nous devons mener
contre l'islam politique
eh bien nous on en a nous ne disposons
pas à l'heure où nous parlons et
certainement pas avec cette loi des
armes pour la gagner un mot peut-être ce
qu'on peut revenir sur leur image il
faisait regarder le débat entre
gérald darmanin et marine le pen la
semaine dernière qu'est ce que vous en
avez pensé rapidement
je suis un passionné de la chose
publique et donc du du débat politique
j'ai trouvé qu'on était là encore dans
dans l'artifice ou la communication
moi ce qui m'intéresse dans le double
jeu que vous venez d'évoquer encore une
fois oui voyez on a la preuve ça fait la
une de l'actualité pendant plusieurs
jours on a un museau l'intérieur qui
accuse madame le pen d'être trop molle
on a deux jours après ami un ancien mise
de l'intérieur qui accuse madame le pen
d'être une ennemie de la république
enfin tout ça c'est du c'est du cynisme
politique c'est de la petite phrase et
qui marine le pen est là où elle est en
partie à cause de l'affaiblissement des
républicains oui alors le lait
il est sympathique monsieur castaner il
était mise de l'intérieur on regarde son
bilan moi je n'ai pas été ministre je
suis un jeune député
et ce qui est certain c'est que le seul
ces quarante dernières années qu'ils
étaient capables de faire reculer le
front national pas pour faire reculer le
front national mais pour convaincre ces
français que nous devons écouter et
comprendre qu'ils s'inquiètent et qui
sont en colère il s'appelle nicolas
sarkozy qui en 2007 a avec monsieur le
pen avait à peine atteint 10% l'élection
présidentielle parce que la grande
erreur de la classe politique de la
pensée unique du politiquement correct à
l'égard du rassemblement national c'est
de jeter des postures morales la
question n'est pas là la question pour
nous c'est de dire aux français et à
ceux qui sont tentés par l'ailé par le
vote rassemblement national nous
comprenons votre colère et nous vous
trompez de choix mais nous allons nous
apporter des solutions concrètes
est ce qu'il est normal aujourd'hui par
exemple qu'il y ait 4111 ficher officier
spf espère t pour pour terrorisme et que
ces gens là continuent à vivre librement
sur le sol national et ne soient pas
expulsés
non ça n'est pas normal est ce qu'il est
logique qu'il n'y ait plus d'écarts en
france entre les revenus du travail et
le revenu l'assistanat
non ça n'est pas normal et c'est à ces
problèmes là que nous devons ré
c'est ça la noblesse de la politique
c'est pas les petites phrases c'est pas
les artifices de communication c'est pas
faire semblant d'inventer des ennemis
tous les matins et tous les soirs
le véritable ennemi qui nous menacent
aujourd'hui qui mena ce qui fonde la
communauté nationale qui menace tous les
français et qui menace les français
musulmans
cet ennemi c'est l'islam politique ce
sont les islamistes
on va continuer à parler de l'actualité
vous parliez de la défenseur des droits
tout à l'heure que l'arrêt dont qui
souhaitent créer des zones son contrôle
d'identité parce qu'elle dit que dans
certains quartiers pour certains jeunes
ça devient insupportable qu est ce que
vous avez pensé de ça mais c'est ce
qu'entend jeu quand je lis ça quand je
découvre ça je me dis j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure mais les élites qui nous
gouvernent
ces gens qui ont d'immenses
responsabilités confiées par les
français défenseur des droits je
rappelle c'est une fonction éminente qui
partait d'une bonne intention en 2008
rassemblés là au delà les autres lol la
haute autorité contre les
discriminations et c'est bon donc ces
gens prennent la parole pour enfermer
dans leur microcosme leur tour d'ivoire
dire n'importe quoi
c'est doublement gravissime c'est grave
parce que c'est faire croire qu'il y
aurait une rupture d'égalité entre tous
les français et se faire croire que la
solution ce serait aujourd'hui de ne
plus avoir de contrôle d'identité demain
pourquoi de avoir ne pas avoir des
quartiers sans policiers on voit bien
qu'on est
ce sont des gens totalement déconnecté
du réel et ceux qui tuent le débat
public français c'est la pensée unique
le politiquement correct et le grand
n'importe quoi
le peuple français n'est pas un peuple
excessif le peuple français est un
peuple épris de justice et de bon sens
et donc sur ce sujet des contrôles
d'identité du soutien à 2,9 à nos forces
de l'ordre nous devons dire répéter
rappeler et faire que dans tous les
quartiers de la république dans tous les
territoires français
la loi s'applique partout et pour tous
de la même année serait dit gérald
darmanin hier soir à poissy que la
police devait être partout il a eu
raison de le rappeler
ah oui ça de manière incontestable mais
souvent quand gérald darmanin parle il a
raison ce que
nous lui reprochons ce sont les actes
c'est son bilan est ce qu'avec lui
l'insécurité recule non est ce qu'avec
lui les policiers et nos gendarmes sont
mieux protégés et - prise à partie non
est-ce que l'immigration recul non donc
la politique c'est être jugé sur ses
actes et sur son bilan
est ce que les policiers soient protégés
- prise à partie nom vous dit avec
gérald darmanin aux commandes
christophe castaner j'imagine qu'à vos
yeux c'était pas mieux qu est-ce qui
qu'est ce qui manque
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qu'ils
auraient dû faire de plus outre le fait
qu'ils ont quand même recruter beaucoup
de policiers de gendarmes au cours de ce
quinquennat
moi je pense qu'il le grand problème en
france on le sait sur les questions de
sécurité et de justice et que
globalement et tout le monde le
reconnaît
nos policiers et nos gendarmes héros
valeureux du quotidien font un travail
remarquable identifie mène des enquêtes
interpelle mais que la justice ne suit
pas et quand on sait que madame taubira
et monsieur hollande puis monsieur
macron qu'il n'a pas rétabli ont
supprimé les peines plancher contre les
récidivistes les tribunaux
correctionnels pour les mineurs quand on
entend les propos de la défenseur des
droits il y a de la part de la classe
politique un angélisme une naïveté c'est
la classe politique qui crée ce
sentiment d'impunité ce que nous
proposons et ça pour vous le point clé
pour mieux protéger les policiers les
gendarmes sont immédiates il en fait il
faudrait deux choses ça suffirait alors
le nord en deux choses premièrement
sanctions immédiates pour tous dit la
théorie du carreau cassé qui avait
popularisé le maire de new york au
moindre petit délit une sanction
d'intérêt général et une sanction
effective premièrement c'est ce que
propose c'est ce que propose eric
dupond-moretti liens des sushis
qu'assurer pack wii bas ce qui pourrait
enfin histoire c'est sa formule en fait
c'est bien de proposer mille ministre
lui donc ils agissent nous aide nous
proposons depuis longtemps et nous
l'avions même mise en oeuvre entre 2007
et 2012 et deuxièmement je vais un peu
plus loin pour voir beaucoup travaillé
sur le sujet je crois que la france
s'honorerait et trouverais une solution
pérenne à cette problématique en créant
dans chaque département français un
centre éducatif fermé à encadrement
militaire pour arracher à encadrement
nourrir pour arracher de nos classes de
nos quartiers
les infime minorité qui pénalise toute
une population à poissy
dernière heure à travers les reportent
les vôtres et ceux de vos collègues des
reportages on voyait bien que ce sont
vingt trente quarante jeunes qui épuise
tout un quartier tout une ville
populaire et ces gens là n'ont plus leur
place dans le quartier appartements bon
il récidive et donc il faut les arracher
les rééduquer et leur rappeler qu'en
france il ya des droits certes mais
avant d'avoir des droits et d'en
revendiquer il y a des devoirs un centre
éducatif fermé par département encadrés
par deux moniteurs oui on va parler de
la crise sanitaire stéphane on va parler
la crise sanitaire et des variants il
bouleverse la donne dans certains
territoires est ce que le gouvernement a
eu raison de ne pas re confiner ces
territoires là ceux qui sont les plus
touchés comme par exemple le grand test
en ce moment alors gérer affronter une
telle crise c'est forcément difficile
est donc loin de nous l'idée de nous en
prendre par principe parce que nous
serions un mouvement d'opposition au
gouvernement notre ce que nous avons
décidé de faire aller christian jacob
damien abad bruno retailleau
systématiquement quotidiennement c'est
d'apporter des pistes d'amélioration
puisque les républicains sont le premier
parti des territoires c'est à dire
qu'avec nos mères nos présidents de
départements nos présidents de région
nous sommes au contact quotidien et
régulier avec les français et ce qui me
marque le plus à travers des rv autre
question tout à fait légitime
c'est un gouvernement déconnecté du réel
et qui a décidé pour gérer cette crise
inédite et très complexe de faire appel
à des experts ou des ministres décide en
tout depuis paris et qu'ils sont souvent
pas d'accord entre eux en plus et donc
ça ne peut pas marcher
quand on voit quand on entend les élus
de moselle
quand on entend les propositions ces
derniers jours du maire de dunkerque
quand on voit les volontés à issoudun
avec un maire socialiste à perpignan et
laignel avec un maire du rassemblement
national
on voit bien et voyez cette transcende
les partis politiques que les élus
locaux appréhende avec beaucoup plus de
précision la réalité d'un territoire
il est des territoires où nous devons
être beaucoup
plus strict et rigoureux compte tenu de
la propagation du virus et des variants
et d'autres adapté plus ruraux par
exemple où on peut sans doute de
redonner un peu d'oxygène et
l'application stricte de décision
nationales qui s'applique partout en
période de crise sur la question
sanitaire à tout le monde de manière
aveugle ça n'est pas la solution qu'on
est dans la côte la cote mal taillée
tout le temps forcément et donc chaque
jour vous avez des polémiques nouvelle
parce que les élus disent mais je ne
comprends pas chez nous en moselle
les règles ne sont pas assez strictes et
ailleurs pourquoi on ne peut pas ouvrir
de manière prudente avec des protocoles
sanitaires strictes
nos musées où nos restaurants la
question de la crise sanitaire elle pose
la question de la crise économique vous
guillaume pelletier vous payez vous
plaidez pour isoler la dette qu vitkine
dit vous êtes une dette de guerre afin
qu'elle devienne une dette perpétuelle
ou une dette à échéance de son temps
vous allez nous en parler mais on a
parlé de votre proposition à eric woerth
qui était notre invité la semaine
dernière regarder ce qu il vous répond
j'aime beaucoup
guillaume mais je non je suis pas
d'accord avec lui mais on a un débat aux
sondes au sein de l heure est au fond le
la loyauté à sa propre formation
politique ce n'est pas le silence c'est
pas d'accepter ce qu'on considère comme
comme une fausse route
donc je ne suis pas d'accord oui bien
sûr c'est une route trop facile j'ai pas
non plus pour faire que les routes
difficiles en temps c'est quand même
bien aussi de faire un peu mais pour
construire la facilité durable une vie
plus simple durablement peut-être plus
ardue on ne peut pas considérer que
cette dette elle ne sera pas remboursé
on peut pas la transformer en dettes
perpétuelles perpétuelle ça veut dire
c'est une date qui n'a pas d'échéance
est ce que je lui dis d'abord mais aussi
j'aime beaucoup eric sincèrement c'est
que on a des débats passionnants et
passionnés sur le maire mais oui j'y
viens et qu'est ce qui fonde notre unité
c'est que nous sommes le grand parti
gaulliste et que croire que au sein du
gaullisme il ya une opposition entre ce
qu'on appelle les libéraux les socios
est une illusion on a besoin d'une
vision
libéral et je suis libéral en partie je
suis attaché à la liberté a beaucoup
plus de liberté
on a besoin d'une dimension sociale et
jeudi eric il le sait depuis cette
émission qu'il m'a mal compris ou je me
suis mal exprimé
il n'a jamais été question de mes propos
vous l'avez d'ailleurs dit de ne pas
rembourser ou d'annuler une dette toute
dette se rembourse ce que j'ai dit avec
françois baroin d'ailleurs ce que je ne
suis pas le seul c'est de dire il y a
deux dettes
il y à la dette publique nationale celle
dont ma génération here it 2500
milliards d'euros d'aidés de dette a été
quasiment à zéro
l'année de ma naissance dans la deuxième
partie des années 70 donc on voit bien
ce dont on est vite
celle ci il faudra rembourser maintenant
à travers des politiques rigoureuses des
équilibres de comptes publics
une lutte contre les dépenses publiques
par exemple je propose la lutte contre
les fraudes fiscales et sociales 100
milliards d'euros chaque année le
montant du déficit public annuel qui
disparaissent des comptes publics parce
que la france manque de sévérité et
d'autorité je propose par exemple la
suppression pendant cinq ans de tout est
social pour un fraudeur social
récidiviste je propose par exemple
pendant cinq ans la suspension d'un
crédit d'impôt pour tout fraudeur fiscal
récidiviste il faut que la france disent
que la lutte contre les fraudes est une
grande priorité pour redonner de
l'oxygène au budget public il nous faut
rembourser la dette publique nationale
la dette cowitz c'est autre chose c'est
une des deux guerres qui nous est tombé
dessus et pour moi il est hors de
question que les classes moyennes que
les français modestes que tous nos
travailleurs nos agriculteurs et les
générations qui viennent paye tout de
suite ce fardeau
ce que nous proposons c'est d'isoler
cette dette des dettes publiques
nationales de la faire prendre en charge
elle d'ailleurs le cas en partie par la
banque centrale européenne est de dire
nous n'allons pas le rembourser tout de
suite nous allons bien sûr la rembourser
mais nous allons dans 30 50 70 ans la
rembourser comment en imaginant des
ressources nouvelles
non pas des impôts sur les citoyens
n'ont pas des impôts sur les français
les classes moyennes mais je donne trois
pistes à nouveau
c'est d'abord par exemple une taxe sur
les transactions financières elles
existent on peut l'augmenter une taxe
sur le
numérique on a on a beaucoup parlé des
gars femmes on peut aller encore
beaucoup plus loin
et puis il y à la question centrale de
l' équilibre environnemental et social
de l'europe vis-à-vis du reste du monde
et je propose cette fameuse c'était dans
le projet des républicains taxe carbone
aux frontières de l'union européenne
donc eric mes yeux je lui redirai l'idée
n'est pas d'annuler la dette
l'idée n'est pas de dire qu'on peut ne
pas rembourser une dette c'est de dire
en l'isolent on la rembourse plus tard
et on imagine non pas d impôt nouveau
sur les français sur ce qui produit ce
qui travaillent mais des taxes aux
frontières de l'union européenne au nom
du monde auquel nous croyons c'est à
dire un monde qui privilégie le commerce
certes international mais que le jeu au
sein de votre parti sur cette rivière et
des bas en permanence qui permettent
on est toujours plus intelligent moi le
premier à écouter l'expérience et les
avis des autres et je crois que la force
avait christian jacob depuis un an c'est
que nous essayons de remettre tout le
monde autour de la table et d'aboutir
pour l'été prochain un projet commun et
je crois qu'on est en train d'y parvenir
un projet très fort sur le régalien avec
de l'autorité sur la sécurité
l'immigration l'avez compris et un
projet d'émancipation d'égalité des
chances d'ascenseur social sur la partie
économique sur la question la dette
publique nationale vous avez utilisé le
terme de rigueur d' équilibre des
comptes ce que ça veut dire que si vous
reveniez aux commandes en 2022
boussouf pro ne riez une nouvelle
politique d'austérité alors non
justement c'est là sans doute ma
différence avec nos aînés des années
précédentes
moi le diagnostic que je pose pour bien
comprendre ma philosophie est simple
pour moi la france sur le plan
économique se meurt parce qu'elle est
trop socialiste à l'intérieur est trop
libéral à l'extérieur je m'explique trop
socialiste à l'intérieur c'est à dire
que nos entrepreneurs nos travailleurs
payent tous les jours des taxes des
charges subissent de la paperasse de
l'administration avec un symbole le code
du travail
il faisait à peine 500 grammes quand je
suis né il fait 2 kg 2 kg 5 aujourd'hui
personne n'y comprend rien je plaide par
exemple avec les républicains pour un
code du travail de 100 pages en nous
appuyant sur les travaux
excellent et passionnant de robert
badinter sur le sur le sujet et à l'
inverse
je prône une protection beaucoup plus
forte à l'extérieur de nos frontières
parce que la mondialisation n'est pas
heureuse parce que la naïveté
commerciale de l'union européenne est
une erreur et regardons ce qu'on fait ce
que font par exemple les pays les plus
libéraux du monde
les britanniques ou les américains ils
font cette nouvelle politique
c'est-à-dire beaucoup plus libérale à
l'intérieur on libère les énergies est
beaucoup plus protectrice à l'extérieur
au fond moi je crois que le principe de
souveraineté est le grand sujet de
l'élection présidentielle de 2022 parce
que la souveraineté c'est tout à la fois
la liberté
je retrouve la maîtrise de ma vie et
c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et c'est la
protection serre que je garde la
maîtrise de mon destin
la souveraineté sera je pense l'un des
grands enjeux et concrètement pour les
gens qui nous écoutent le remboursement
de la dette est ce que vous leur dites
s'il va falloir travailler plus c'est un
discours qu'on entend et chez les
républicains est ce qu'il va falloir
faire une réforme des retraites est ce
qu'il va falloir payer plus d'impôts
alors c'est l'âge encore je suis
différent travailler davantage oui la
france est l'un des pays où le travail
le moins disons le clairement on
travaille pas assez la france devient
trop souvent une société de loisirs
plutôt qu'une société de travail il faut
jamais oublier que le loisir et la
récompense d'une vie de travail et c'est
pal inverse il faut bien expliquer à
tous ceux qui vivent en france pour pour
produire pour créer la richesse
il faut travailler c'est le travail qui
permet les motivations kurt oui par la
liberté permettent par référendum
d'entreprise au sein de chaque
entreprise à chaque entreprise avec ses
salariés de décider d'un temps de
travail entre 35 et 40 heures mais moi
je ne veux plus d'une politique
d'austérité qui s'applique sur les
travailleurs les entrepreneurs et les
classes moyennes
donc je pense que c'est d'abord à l'état
de se réchauffer une politique nouvelle
sur bientôt non une politique nouvelle
sur l'immigration je vais vous prendre
un exemple les étrangers ont accès en
moyenne à 125 milliards des 600
milliards dette sociale en france
eh bien nous proposons de conditionner
l'accès à tout est social un étranger à
cinq années de travail et de résidence
il y a plein d'économies à faire avant
d'envisager de d'asphyxier les français
c'est une nouvelle vision de la
politique et d'une saine et rigoureuse
gestion des deniers publics et on peut
en parler encore longtemps il ya
beaucoup de propositions mais il nous
reste très peu de temps pour un dernier
mode politique stéphane oui à propos des
régions
vous ce que vous serez pas un candidat
vous même finalement non j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi a rejeté ces cinq dernières
années et je le reste le leader régional
de ma région président du groupe
elle est rude et y indépendance et une
mission passionnante les régions
centrales de leur centre val de loire
bien sûr mais le fait d'être un jeune
député que la crise se soit abattu
partout en france les difficultés qu'on
rencontre en loir-et-cher avec notre
président du conseil départemental qui
arrête la politique la volonté de
rebâtir une majorité départementale
et puis surtout l'incertitude liée au
calendrier régional présidentielle je ne
peux pas tout faire je ne veux pas tout
faire et c'est aussi ça la politique
c'est d'être collectif le candidat c'est
nicolas forissier c'est un ami il a une
super personnalité une très belle
expérience et il pourra rassembler la
droite et le sens je vais l'aider à 100%
moi je vais me concentrer et me
consacrer aux loir-et-cher d'une part et
puis vous l'avez bien compris
avoir ce rôle dans l'élection
présidentielle pour le rôle central avec
d'autres que de réconcilie la famille de
bâtir une équipe de france et de dire à
xavier bertrand à bruno retailleau avait
les rip crèche à david lisnard à tous
nos talents
on a besoin de tout le monde on a besoin
de bâtir une équipe
une seule personne ne pourra pas réparer
la france est l'enjeu qui vient c'est de
réparer la france s'en fera dans sa
tombe de cavage qu'un nom sur le
bulletin présidentielle wheels elle il
choisir à l'été ça me semblerait assez
naturel et dyer enlevé aujourd'hui il ya
une dynamique naturelle
xavier bertrand semble avoir cette
dynamique on verra c'est lui le mieux
placé à l'heure actuelle pour vous
aujourd'hui
oui on verra ensemble collectivement de
manière apaisée qui est le meilleur
entraîneur et sélectionneur de cette
équipe de france mais la priorité c'est
de bâtir une équipe de ripon 114 l
éleveur par une primaire par les
sondages est ce que c'est les sondages
qui vont décider de votre candidat pas
que c'est vous savez une présidentielle
c'est une alchimie entre une
personnalité et notre peuple et donc
tout le monde verra bien
cet été et à l'automne qui est capable
de fédérer de rassembler et de gagner
parce que après deux élections
présidentielles perdues
la question n'est pas de témoigner c'est
d'échapper au duel mortifère entre
monsieur macron et les extrêmes et de
réparer la france autour de pilier très
simple la valeur du travail est une
valeur centrale
la valeurs de laïcité d'ordre et
d'autorité face à l'islam politique
et puis ce rêve perdu aujourd'hui de
concorde nationale d'unités de liberté
et de réconciliation entre paris et la
province
un vaste débat que nous allons devoir
porter avec beaucoup de détermination
parce que la france le mérite tri on
espère vous viendrez nous en parler vexé
d'avoir été notre invité on regarde la
une nous resterons stéphane fonds de
solidarité pourquoi les aides tarder
c'est à la une de votre journal à demain
stéphane merci beaucoup merci à vous et
on passe aussi de clubs détaillera la
mutuelle nationale 4
[Musique]